thing I love Mexicans as he holds OG's
arm that's how he did that one like
we're no prejudices see I invited him
that's basically what he said there are
no prejudices here you know do what you
want drink what you want put in your
body whatever you want or put in someone
else's body whatever you feel whatever
you desire put in your body or in
someone else's body you know it shut the
[__] up did this man just say I'm trying
to get the orgy started but I'm a little
shy so let me beat around the bush
whatever you want to put in your body
and I went
I like the LG
all right just making sure that you
heard
I look around and nobody's like doing
the eye I'm like
what kind of party I come to man
[Applause]